hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played in 1970 in
herzegovi blitz tournament uh in
montenegro
and uh it's uh it's a game between amy
hill tide and
robert james fisher now it's a it's a
really it's a really wild game and we've
shown some of the games
between the two of them uh they haven't
played a lot of games together even
though they were active
uh pretty much in the same time only 11
classical games between the two of them
and we have covered most of them we
haven't covered all
but this is the one i decided to show
you today uh why i'm showing you this
game today between fisher
and thai and well i will refer to him as
style from now on even though i
did refer to him as tal in some some of
the previous videos
uh but uh that's only because i thought
i was doing it wrong previously
uh and then you know i saw everyone
online was calling him tal
and then i decided to do that as well
when it is in fact tied
uh but okay i i might just call him
misha so i don't confuse you any further
uh but okay uh so it's a five minute
tournament a double round robin uh
between some of the strongest players
that were active in those days and uh
uh well it was just an incredibly strong
tournament and of course
both misha and the bobby here were the
favorites to win the tournament other
players were
uh so um amongst them uh
petrossian braunstein hort matullo which
smiths love
so a really really strong tournament for
those days uh and
well this is one of the games i decided
to show you as today is misha's 84th
birthday uh or it would be if he was
still alive so i
i think it's fitting we show uh at least
one game
so without further ado let's check it
out and then we're gonna discuss it
a bit more so misha with the white
pieces opens with
e4 and fischer of course goes for the
sicilian defense we have c5
knight to f3 and d6 and this is the 1970
fisher so the
the fisher that completely obliterated
everyone in the world
bear in mind uh and here knight the c3
so not going for the open sicilian with
the d4
as this is a blitz game but this is the
old school blitz so no uh
increments no funny business this is
just five plus zero
uh and you know uh we play until the the
last man standing so here
uh e5 uh gaining control of the of the
d4 square
and now bishop the c4 uh misha just
continues developing with bishop to e7
and d3 now we have knight to f6 fisher
also makes room
uh for castling and we have castles by
white
knight the c6 uh and now knight to e1
today knight the g5 is uh what's
what would be played going after the uh
this uh f7 pawn but in those days
knights to e1
was uh was very popular you're preparing
f4
and then the game continues we have
castles by fischer
uh and uh f4 by misha uh we have a6
preparing b5 to
uh start uh advancing those pawns on the
queen side and of course uh
misha stops it with a4 uh e captures on
f4 we have bishop captures on f4 and now
bishop to e6 and here
uh tile trades on uh on e6 we have
captures captures and
bishop back to g3 not allowing any any
discoveries if the knight moves then the
bishop could be quite weird they're on
f4
uh and here queen to b6 by fischer is
saying
uh you really haven't achieved all that
much i've now developed my queen your
b-pawn is under attack i've connected my
rook so i i have a very strong center
and you have the white pieces and you
really haven't achieved all that much
and here well you could defend it with
rook to b1
uh there's no need to do that misha just
goes queen to d2 he offers the b2 pawn
even though the b2 pawn is poison
uh or poisonous depending on which which
you prefer uh so if you go
capture it uh then it you're just lost
because after rogue b1 queen a3
rule b3 traps the queen and it's game
over or rather it doesn't trap the queen
black does have this capture that
attacks the queen but black will suffer
severe material loss so instead after
queen d2 we have knight to g4 by fisher
he says okay first we're gonna do some
trades and then i might capture that
pawn
uh but also you constantly have to worry
about c4 does this discovery do anything
or or maybe not
uh so here knight back to f3 by misha
and now
knight to d4 again capturing here would
be even worse now because
now you just have rook f to be one and
the queen is immediately lost
so knight f3 and knight to d4 oh sorry
wrong knight
knight to d4 now putting pressure on the
under knight on f3 and threatening to
pick it up and
bust open uh the pawn structure here
so rook 8 to b1 you have to keep an eye
on that pawn here
and now knight captures on f3 uh we have
g captures you could also capture with
the rook but it doesn't
really help all that much so instead g
captures and now
knight to e5 uh re-maneuvering the
knight the knight is now on an excellent
square
and even though you could capture here
and mess up a black spawn structure
black doesn't really mind here because
he will have excellent control of d4 and
f4 squares
and uh well the white king is wide open
not too much to worry about here
and uh well especially since it's a
blitz game so here
king g2 by misha uh e although f4
was uh also a possibility the f3 pawn is
under attack so f4 does
uh make the problem go away but okay
misha has a different idea we have kink
the g2
and now comes knight back to g6
uh we have knights to e2 gaining more
control of the f4 square
and now knights the h4 uh knights to h
for with check and here you have to
do something because the f3 pawn is
under attack if you move the king you're
going to lose it if you
put the king in front of the rook then
the rook no longer defends it you're
again going to lose it so here
misha accepts the knight we have bishop
captures on h4 and now
just b4 the king is no longer on this
diagonal so you can
bust open the b file so fischer goes
back queen to c7
and now a trade on c5 we have captures
captures and
a5 misha now gains control of the b6
square he wants to play rook b6
doubling rooks on the b file is possible
however
uh it's uh very likely that fischer will
double rooks on the f-file and you kind
of want to keep this rook here to defend
uh this lonely f3 pawn and this is
exactly what fischer does he goes rook
to f6
and f4 now the the pawn will be
much easier to defend on f4 as it's
defended many times here than it would
be on f3
we have rook eight to f8 and now as
there there is no immediate danger of
capturing uh
or on f4 uh misha does this very nice
rook lift so rook to b6
uh and now comes uh bishop the g5 by
fischer and now
uh of course you cannot capture the
bishop because you lose the rook here
and there uh well the the four pawn is
attacked four times so you have to do
something here
so misha defends it with e5 he says okay
now the queen is no longer attacking the
pawn here
and you don't have this very sneaky
queen captures on e5
as the queen on d2 is also hanging
because after pawn captures the rook is
also under attack so it would work if
the rook was not on f6 but here you just
lose the rook on f6 and you are down a
whole rook but it is an interesting
position so here
rook to f5 instead now uh with
such ideas are possible and here comes
rook captures on e6 and here
uh with rook to f5 fischer is actually
threatening to capture
here and probably a move like queen to
e3 just defending that
uh works uh wonders for misha uh but uh
he went for rook captures on e6 instead
and now it's uh well it's a bit
different uh because he
although he did create a very wonderful
past e pawn he allows queen to c7
and we've reached the position from the
thumbnail now the rook is under attack
and also the f4 pawn is again attacked
four times and you can't really add
another defender
so misha goes back rook to d6 and
now comes bishop captures on f4 which is
uh
not the the most precise idea rook
captures an e5
again works because you cannot capture
here there's nothing on f6
and the queen would be hanging on d2 so
but it's a bliss game like i said blitz
game no increment uh we're not going to
over analyze it as
they did not over analyze it well while
playing it so bishop captures on f4 now
attacks the queen
and we have a capture fest on f4 so rook
captures on f4 we have knight cap
we have rook captures knight captures uh
and now queen captures
queen captures on f4 rook captures on f4
and now
rook to d7 misha gets his rook to the
seventh rank
uh it promotes it to to a pig and now
that uh the that pawn is very weak then
this pawn will be weak and it's very
hard to see
totally fisher will be able to do
something about this so fischer goes
rook to a4 he wants to start by
eliminating the a5 pawn
but now misha doesn't even bother
capturing on b7 he instead
pushes uh the pawn here uh all the way
to e6 so now the king cannot come to f7
and if you allow this uh could be could
be very problematic so keen to f8 and
now
rook to f7 check first king the e8 and
only now
rook captures on g7 now you could also
not capture the pawn and start bringing
the king into the game then if
rook captures then your king can just go
all the way up the board that's one
possibility
but okay misha goes for rook captures on
g7 and
rook captures an a5 by fischer we have
rook captures on b7
and now uh rook goes all the way back to
a2 puts pressure on the on the c2 pawn
and it's
four pawns uh misha three pawns fisher
but uh you know it's it's a rook sand
game
and anything can still happen uh so here
king to
f3 you could also capture an h7 it is a
possibility but now misha starts
bringing the king into the game
uh if you can bring your king to e4 to
d5 and here to control
these three squares then it's uh very
likely it's
it's just game over so here rook
captures on c2
and only now rook captures on h7 so
eliminating this pawn is well guarding
the h2 pawn
we have c for now a very sneaky idea
uh trying to trade off as many pawns as
possible but
misha just advances the pawn to d4 so
pawn to d4
we have c3 by fischer already a very
dangerous pass pawn
and now we have d5 again king to e4
always a possibility
whoa uh if you get your king to d6 it's
very likely that
fischer can just resign but misha
prefers the two connected past pawns so
d5 and now rook to d2 attacking one of
the
past pawns but king to e for now
defending it
with c2 by fischer now preparing pawn to
c1 to bring a queen into the game and of
course
rook the c7 the only move that works for
uh for misha
king the d8 attacking the rook and now
comes rook to c4 so now
uh atar is ready to go king to e5 he's
gonna push d6 c7 check and so on
and fischer has to figure out what to do
he cannot promote the pawn he cannot
prepare promotion because he loses the
pawn
so uh the only thing left is a5 so he
advances this pawn
and now comes h4 by misha he wants to
i guess increase his chances as much as
possible even though king to e5 wins on
the spot
uh there's no defense against king the
d6 e7 check and
rook to c8 that that's just game uh but
uh like we said never forget
it's a blitz game no increment five
minutes so here they could
they could i have no idea what was the
time on the clock when this game was
played
in this particular moment so it could be
like maybe they have 10 10 seconds on
the clock i don't know
uh so instead we have h for by misha uh
and now
a4 by fischer he continues pushing uh
pushing his pawn so of course
uh misha cannot capture because then the
the queening square is no longer
defended
and now king e5 misha finally plays the
only winning move he's preparing to
bring the king further into the game
and of course win this game and here a3
by fischer
and now a3 perhaps is something
that changes the position drastically so
feel free to pause the video and
find the winning move for misha while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
move
we've discussed this entire video and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's king to d6 the only
winning move now all of these squares
are covered
uh and there's no defense uh e7 check is
coming you're gonna have to move the
king then rook comes then uh
pawn promotes with check it's just all
over for example
a2 you're just going to play e7 check
you're going to have to move the king
rook c8 check king goes to f7 and now
uh the promotion comes with check which
is extremely important because uh of
course
fischer also wants to promote his pawns
and now after king to f6
is just a very easy checkmate or working
to g7 doesn't really matter everything
ends in checkmate here check check check
and now let's say check check and the
mate
uh not not much for black to do here so
uh here
like we've said after a3 king to d6 is
deadly however
misha went for d6 he just really loves
his two connected past pawns and
uh he wants to push them as far far away
as possible but
here it just doesn't work uh here we
have rook to e2 with
check and now misha is forced to repeat
moves and
accept the draw here for example this
and we we have a very nice draw here for
example check check check
and you cannot go king to c6 or
somewhere because now a2
is uh incredibly strong and you don't
have the rook uh
to follow it up with rook to it for
example e7 check you can go here
uh and if this check comes you can
simply play rook characters on d7 and
there's no continuation here
so instead after this rook to e2 check
misha doesn't repeat moves king d5 king
e5 but rather goes king to
f5 and it's still uh
well now it's winning for fisher and
that's uh that's a pretty big
problem if you're you know a white and
you've been ready to win this entire
game
and now a2 is winning for fisher but
it's a blitz game and you know mistakes
are here to be made so here
fisher continues with rook to f2 check
and now misha can just go back king e5
and then he again has the position where
he's able to
repeat moves which is probably what
fischer wanted he wanted to go
try to go back and then he can go uh you
know start uh
checking in with the rook however we
have king to g4
misha really wants to win this game as
he he really doesn't like to
to draw his games uh with the white
pieces but now
we have a2 now uh there could be a
problem
uh because well this pawn could queen on
the next move
and there's a problem with e7 e7 check
doesn't work because after king d7 and
rook the c7
check uh you can just capture here and
even though you get a queen into the
game just king captures on c7
and yes it's a queen against a rook but
a queen against the rook and two
uh pawns are ready to raid the queen so
the the best white can do here is just
hope to
uh you know continue checking the black
king even if you somehow connect
the the check with the uh with the rook
you know
if you if you can fork the rook it's
very unlikely that you will be able
not very unlikely it's impossible you
will not be able to fork them
uh and grab the rook with czech because
uh you know black
is not an idiot uh so that will not work
so after a2 we have d7 instead of e7
but now uh now it's just completely
winning for fischer and here uh
of course uh what misha wants is for
fisher to promote his spawn and then
have this check followed by bringing a
queen into the game with tempo
however fischer just plays king to e7
and now there's no promotion and
rook here doesn't really do anything i
mean it does do something but uh
not not all that much because after rook
the c8
now threatening to bring the uh queen
into the game with
check uh fischer just played rook to d2
and now this square is covered
and there isn't all that much you can do
rookie check was played
king to f6 uh and now uh
there's just not enough for example if
you bring your queen into the game and
black
trades here captures captures you cannot
stop both of the pawns and you're just
going to lose the game
so instead after king to f6 e7 was
played by misha
but now fischer just played rook
captures on d7
uh and uh it was in this position uh
animal 51 that uh
that uh mihil ty uh resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
one of the pawns will queen next you're
gonna lose this pawn and
that's just it so if you're wondering
why i'm showing a game misha lost on his
birthday well does because we've already
covered all of the games that he won
against
fisher and i thought uh well maybe maybe
just to
show a few more games against fisher
before we uh
show some other games because there
there will be other uh you know
birthdays and we have to cover some
other games as well
uh but yeah er that's why i showed it
and it was a really really wild one
because uh it's interesting uh
the two of them met at the beginning of
the tournament so the first two games
were between the two of them
and fisher won both of them and then
fisher after beating misha who was the
second favorite to win the tournament
uh continued and just crushed everyone
in the tournament
the the final result for fischer was 17
wins
four draws and only one loss and the
second place was won by of course none
other than
then misha here but fisher had four and
a
half
points more than misha in the end of the
tournament and
if you're interested in who is this
mystery person that defeated the
defeated fisher
uh in this tournament it is none other
than viktor korchnoy
uh he was able to snatch away one point
uh one point from fisher
uh so yeah uh and these are
the the standings between the two of
them so if you look at
the final standings in classical games
uh uh misha defeated
fisher four to two with five draws in
classical games
we've shown all the games where uh with
where tile defeated fisher so
i if you guys are interested in that i
will put uh an entire link to the 1959
candidates tournament in the description
below so you can check out games from
that tournament that uh all four games
uh then misha one are in that tournament
and if we include rapid and exhibition
games then
uh the two of them tied four wins
uh each with five draws so that's if we
include
uh rabbit and exhibition games but in
classical uh misha is just you know
uh uh ahead so really really exciting
exciting stuff and uh like i said this
was 1970s fisher so the one that uh
destroyed the the palma de mallorca
intra zonal the candidates uh
matches against everyone and then
defeated uh
so this was this was a monster and uh
well basically the only reason
uh tar did not win this game is because
uh
the lulu lost the game is because he
really wanted to win the game
uh with uh with the white pieces uh so
uh that's uh that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it
uh we might show some more between the
two of them but we don't have uh
all that many so we have to save them
like we did uh
between misha and niche medinav we're
going to cover
all of them at some point so
once again i do hope you enjoyed it and
um
well also i want to say that misha would
not mind if i
showed a game on his birthday where he
lost against fisher because he really
he really appreciated fisher and you
know when when misha fell ill during the
uh the candidates tournament uh uh in
curacao
and he was in the hospital fisher was
the only one who came to visit him and
you know play some
uh probably friendly games against him
you know check out some positions maybe
not play full games
uh but uh pretty sure that misha would
not mind me
showing uh such a game so at some point
we might
cover this entire tournament as i
believe all of the games were saved or
maybe maybe just all of fisher's games
but i think most of the games were saved
maybe even all
so yeah we'll uh we'll see how it goes
uh so yeah once again i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
uh tom petrie frederick jacobson uh
tori indredak duncan weinkolt uh
and prodromos matsuokas for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
uh i will see you soon uh continuing the
morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and uh whatever else happens in the
chess world uh so thank you all
uh i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and i've just
realized
a video on a blitz game lasted 21
minutes so
sorry about that